Elon Musk responding to Viva Frey you
guys know Viva Frey we've had him on the
show a bunch of times Aviva tweeted out
if this happens it will be the beginning
of Trump's re-election and he's
referring to this this prosecution and
if they were to actually arrest and
fingerprint Trump and all that Elon
responded and said if this happens Trump
will be re-elected in a landslide
Victory okay so Elon Musk gets it the
this is what these weirdos do they
Butterfly Effect this entire thing right
like uh they make these things bigger
it's just like let let Trump run and let
the Republicans decide is is this the
future
of the Republican party is DeSantis the
future whatever it might be but instead
they just want to pile on and endless
the vindictive vindictiveness and the
endlessness uh it just does not stop
[Music]
thank you